from hokey death scenes too badly
written monologues and characters
appearing that make no sense in the
context of the movie the 2010s had many
cringe-worthy acting moments that will
go down in cinema infamy these are just
a few of the worst offenders of the
decade the concluding chapter of
Christopher Nolan's gritty Dark Knight
trilogy and it with a bunch of explosive
bangs thanks to Bane and his associates
but also with a bit of a fizzle
featuring the super unfortunate in movie
death of Marion Cotillard Miranda Tate
aka
Talia al Ghul after orchestrating a
series of huge protests with a rising
death toll of innocent Gothamites Talia
al Ghul crashes her truck and with a
melodramatic gasp inside falls back dead
but not before detonating her final bomb
[Music]
the moment is so incredibly hokey and
laughable that it would have been
perfectly matched in the campy Adam West
led Batman TV series but coming during
Nolan's take on the franchise it feels
hugely out of place we don't see a lot
of Shakespearean villain style
monologues these days and it's for good
reason
they don't tend to sound authentic
outside Shakespeare's context even for a
megalomaniacal character and instead
come across is painful exposition that
ends up being funny rather than menacing
for example look at Eddie redmayne's
portrayal of Balam Abraxas in the
Wachowskis space opera Jupiter ascending
which follows a young earth woman named
Jupiter who learns she's actually
interstellar royalty a revelation that
puts balam's control of the universe in
jeopardy Jupiter ascending is filled
with fringe worthy moments from Channing
Tatum's eye liner - Kunis's overly
earnest performance but Redmayne wins
for one of the worst acted scenes of the
past decade I create destroyed in the
Year sense Redmayne himself has admitted
his work in Jupiter ascending left a lot
to be desired
even told GQ in an interview I won a
prize for it for the worst performance
of the year so yeah it was a pretty bad
performance by all accounts for many
Harry Potter fans the fact that Hermione
Granger ended up with Ron Weasley and
not Harry was an unsatisfying way to end
the characters story Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows Part 1 did its part
to muddy those waters featuring an
intimate scene between Harry and
Hermione while Ron is off looking for
Salazar Slytherin 'he's locket Horcrux
in order to make a despondent Hermione
buck up for a minute Harry asks her to
dance and they hip and dip around
awkwardly - Nick caves haunting song Oh
children the actors look incredibly
uncomfortable not just dancing with each
other but on their own and no amount of
fancy camerawork could have helped them
pull off the scene if it weren't for
Nick caves vocals and beautiful lyrics
the moment would have been a complete
disaster
even as it foreshadows Ron's eventual
jealous blowup about Harry and Hermione
'he's possibly romantic feelings for
each other Quentin Tarantino has a long
history of inserting himself into his
movies and Django Unchained is arguably
one of his worst cameo moments this
antebellum
revisionist history features Jamie
Foxx's Django an escaped slave assisted
by dentist turned bounty hunter dr. King
Schultz out to wreak bloody vengeance on
slavers including Calvin Candie who has
kidnapped his love Hildy Bunn shaft as
Django's rampage heats up the movie cuts
to a flashback in which Tarantino
appears speaking in a dodgy Australian
accent before Django kills him that
completely derails the climax of the
film yahoo news UK suggested that
Tarantino sported an Australian accent
because he couldn't do a passable
southern one which begs the question of
why II was even included in the movie at
all other than as director sized ego
that is sometimes there's nothing even
the best actors can do when the script
veers into overwrought territory which
is unfortunately the case with
interstellar christopher nolan story
about the intersection of science
technology and family as well as
wormholes and event horizons
since nolan can't make a movie without a
mind-bending twist or two sadly the
audience is well yanked out at the
complicated but well-crafted story when
Anne Hathaway's character Emilia brand
rattles off a Hallmark greeting card of
a monologue that sounds considerably
less than scientific love is the one
thing we're capable of perceiving that
transcends dimensions of time and space
this line comes as brand makes her case
that love is a quantifiable force in the
universe that can actually be used as a
tool of measurement a pretty ridiculous
concept even though in the logic of the
movie she turns out to be right but just
because the movie makes the concept real
doesn't mean that this speech
introducing it works and even Hathaways
considerable talent can't make the
monologue sound anything but forced
thankfully the scene is only two minutes
of pure cheddar and an otherwise
compelling sci-fi drama but it's also
enough to stick out it's one of the
worst acted scenes of the past decade
three Americans are hailed as heroes for
foiling an attack on a high-speed train
in Europe it was a real-life event that
made news around the globe three
American men traveling from Amsterdam to
Paris
Thornton a would-be terrorist mass
shooter through their own quick thinking
and selfless bravery Spencer stone
Anthony Sadler and Alek skarlatos
wrestled the weapon from the gunman and
saved the life of one of his victims
American Marco galleon who was the first
to identify the terrorists later French
authorities found the shooter had been
armed with 300 rounds of bullets more
than enough to have killed most of the
people on the train had he not been
stopped Clint Eastwood directed the 5/17
to Paris and in a surprising move
decided to cast the four american
survivors including the gunshot victim
ooh galleon as themselves
unfortunately the experiment didn't
exactly pay off in this big-budget
Hollywood recreation of real events
these men are heroes and did an
incredible service for their fellow
passengers but they're not professional
actors and it's very clear to audiences
[Music]
the 2010s saw Nicolas Cage and a number
of dreadful movies but Drive angry
stands out as one of the worst the actor
delivers a furious but empty turn is
John Milton a man who has been dead ten
years and returns to earth from Hell in
order to save his infant granddaughter
from being sacrificed to Satan his
one-liners fall so flat that you'd think
an ACME truck rolled over them nothing
of this earth can kill me not of this
earth it's hard to pick a least favorite
scene the absurd gunfight sex scene
Milton peeing fire cage rebounded in
later years with more critically
acclaimed fare like the gonzo Mandy but
for a decent chunk of the decade it
seemed like he may have permanently lost
his way and Drive angry is a perfect
example of why check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]